my name is parisa
this talk is uh called chrome security
special sauce
before i start um one of the risks of of
spending most of my life working from
the cloud is that when the cloud is down
things don't look nice so unfortunately
you're going to have to look at these
slides in pdf but
it should be fine also before i get into
the meat of my talk i probably should
give a couple disclaimers
so i feel like a bit a little bit of an
outsider or an imposter here
i'm not a developer i know how to
program and
i even have a computer science degree
but
most of the engineering work i've done
is actually
in finding bugs and vulnerabilities in
breaking code
not actually building things so
this talk is unlikely to help you become
a better developer i still think it will
be interesting and hopefully useful to
people
um but i want to give that disclaimer uh
in case you want to sneak out um also
this is the first time i'm giving this
so we will see how it goes um
so with that shining that shiny
introduction
uh let's get into the actual uh talk
so my name is parisa i
currently manage chrome's security
engineering team
i've been at google
who is the company that built chrome
for about six years the first five of
which i spent as
a engineer breaking web applications
and then about six months ago i moved to
chrome and now work on security
hopefully some of you use chrome or at
least know what it is
it just celebrated its fifth birthday as
a browser
a couple weeks ago and
earlier this year it it just broke 50
market share so it's actually kind of
popular
and chrome was built with three core
principles in mind
that a browser should be fast it should
be
simple and easy to use and it should be
secure
so so security is a core principle and
that means that everyone
cares about it and has to care about it
but i have the luxury
of being able to care about security
full-time and myself and about
20 other engineers obsess about security
and work on security exclusively within
chrome
so just to give you some dynamics as i
said about 20 engineers we're spread
across the world
across different google offices and
at the end of the day we do whatever is
helpful or necessary to
make chrome secure and to keep chrome
users safe
but what this practically means
or at least most commonly means is we
help to design
and implement features in chrome that
have some security relevance we help to
find
and fix security bugs we help
respond to any vulnerabilities in chrome
that are reported to us
or kind of security of infrastructure in
building chrome it's a
it's an open source project so there's
people that contribute to chrome outside
of google
and as i said you know at the end of the
day we do whatever is
is helpful to keep chrome safe and our
users safe
so browser security why should you care
um hopefully it's not too controversial
to say that security internet security
is
is an important thing um and it's
something the internet
it's not this you know fad that's going
away in
you know the past 20 years the internet
has evolved from
this small you know network for elite
geeks
um into something that really is
the infrastructure for so much of our
activity mainstream activity
and it's something that people are
moving their personal financial
digital assets to and really entrusting
you know internet providers with
crime internet crime has surpassed
drug crime um i think in 2009 symantec
made that claim and
statistics around internet security are
always i'm always sort of speculative
but a claim like that is is not
surprising to me at all and it's
something
um you know i i believe in for me it's
it's good job security but it's really
scary and i think
internet security has gone from
obscurity to something that's at the
forefront
of consumer minds and and the concerns
of of companies and even as we've seen
in the last year
it's it's something that's being
discussed and acted on at a national
security level too so
security is important um bad guys are
out there
and browser is a very attractive target
for somebody that wants to commit some
crime
why is that so everyone uses a browser i
imagine that everybody who has a laptop
open or is looking at their phone right
now has some browser running and it's
usually the first program that
you know you open and keep open for the
duration of your your usage of the
device
so large user base
for an attacker attacker gets easy
remote access
all they have to really do to interact
with your browsers get you to open up a
web page
and you know at the end of the day a
browser is just a really complex piece
of of software which makes it difficult
to secure
chrome has several millions of lines of
code
most of which are security critical it's
constantly changing we're constantly
adding features
some of which are sort of experimental
and maybe
not as as well tested because we have
this this model of launch and iterate
and a browser is just exposed to a lot
of untrusted
potentially hostile content so it's a
great target for attackers
it's a really hard thing to defend and
this is why you should care about about
browser security
so the bulk of my talk is going to be go
to to go over a couple of the top
threats
um you know as that you should be aware
of
as you as you use the internet and then
some of the specific things that chrome
has done to try to thwart these
uh attacks so we're gonna talk about
browser exploits
uh phishing and malware sites and then
attacks to to ssl
so browser exploits what is a browser
exploit
an exploit is a piece of malicious code
written by an attacker that aims to
achieve
remote code execution on some victim's
machine so typically
what they will do is find a bug
find a way to exploit this bug and
achieve some security goal with it
and the bug in our case we're going to
be talking about bugs in the browser
that are reachable by interacting with a
browser
common targets for for browser exploits
are going to be the actual
browser code itself and then anything
that a user would commonly add to a
browser
most commonly this is going to be
plugins and i've listed a couple of the
popular ones that people are probably
familiar with
and that are very commonly attacker
targets
because large user base complexity and
kind of a history of insecurity
so what does google what does you know
chrome do to
thwart browser exploitation um
at a high level this you know probably
isn't especially interesting i'm going
to get into some
specifics but you know we find we look
for bugs we find security bugs and fix
them
and then actually update users um and we
also acknowledge
the reality of of bugs and make sure to
architect chrome in a way
such that you know the impact of any
individual bug is limited
so some specifics first finding bugs
so you know there's of course all the
traditional ways
we we find bugs at chrome there's a
best practice that everybody reviews
every code change
and we do a lot of education to teach
people about classes of security bugs so
hopefully while you're reviewing code
you you find things that way
there's also um you know more
traditional testing and qa that
can be used to find security bugs but
the one
um you know sort of cool way that i
think
we find security bugs in chrome is via
fuzzing
so this is a a term or that we use to
describe a technique of testing
where we essentially throw malformed
input at a program
with the aim of getting it to crash or
getting it to behave in some unexpected
way
exposing a bug and then the hope is that
this bug has security consequences and
and then we fix it so
in a really naive fuzzer would just be
to you know output random
dev random into the program wait till it
crashes
and then investigate the source of the
crash and something as simple as this is
actually extremely effective
there's a there's a white paper written
i think it's probably almost been
between five and ten years ago that
did something very similar to this um
against a lot of
uh popular linux utilities and found
dozens of security bugs
so something really basic can actually
be very effective and i encourage you
to um to try something like this
in the software that you write but
there's there's ways to make this more
sophisticated
and fuzzing is a really hot topic right
now um in security research
because of just how effective it
actually is with relatively minimal
work you don't need to understand how a
piece of software works to find security
bugs and and then
leverage them so some of the things you
would you would consider when trying to
optimize your fuzzer
obviously code coverage so the more
lines of code that your fuzzer can touch
the more likely you are to find bugs
performance is is always a consideration
you want a fuzzer that is
using a minimal set of test cases so
that it's
you know not just churning in the
background well unless you're trying to
slack off
and and i've when i've sort of felt down
i've i've started a fuzzer on like a
thursday and
then distracting myself and convinced
myself i was actually working as like
this fuzzer
is fuzzy in the background but in
general you want something
that works fast at google we have
just massive access to resources so our
fuzzers run
on upwards of 2000 cores
they're just throwing test cases of the
software that we're trying to assess
so reproducibility is an important part
of
fuzzing effectiveness you need to be
able to identify
the actual test case that caused the
crash so that you can
you know go and investigate it and then
how you actually
create your test cases um is is also
something to optimize so in
my basic fuzzer i'm just throwing random
input
but if i'm trying to fuzz something that
is protocol or aware
or expect some some type of format in
the input
then this probably is not going to be
very effective because it's going to hit
some exception case
early on in the program and then not
actually test
the bulk of of the functionality so
if i wanted to test some image parsing
library for example one thing i could do
is start with all valid images
and then using that corpus
do modifications to the images like bit
flipping
in certain fields and that would
actually
make it more likely i would be able to
test more of the functionality
so that's called mutation based buzzing
another approach
is to you know learn the protocol
or format of what you're trying to parse
and then
to algorithmically generate certain
input that would that will adhere to
some of those rules and maybe violate
other ones to try to find bugs
so fuzzing has been extremely effective
for us to find
security bugs in chrome and other google
software
we have a a piece of infrastructure that
we affectionately call cluster fuzz
which fuzzes on as i said
thousands of cores against the latest
version of chrome
and if it detects a crash it's able to
find the test case
um make it easy for a developer to fix
by you know isolating
identifying where the crash actually
came from and and some indicators as to
how to fix it
and then it will actually test the fixes
as well
so we fuzz chrome code we also fuzz
a lot of third-party code that chrome
depends on
and this is nice because if we find bugs
in this code then we can fix it upstream
and it means that other open source
projects
can benefit from from these security
patches as well
and something that is maybe surprising
to some people is we actually will fuzz
uh third-party binaries as well so
things that we don't actually
have access to the code for but that we
still are invested
in the security of so in particular
google has fuzzed adobe flash the adobe
flash player
using our infrastructure and we've along
with adobe
you know found and fixed hundreds of
bugs and
flash actually comes with chrome
natively so it's really important
in that sense that that flash is secure
and um this is something that
you know we we've used um
uh to to improve security of flash too
so we find bugs um that's one way
uh we try to thwart
active exploitation but we also
recognize
that you know okay we have about 20
engineers working at google and
all of chrome cares about security
we have automated testing but there's a
lot of people outside of google
and outside of the chromium project to
leverage as well so a second thing that
we do to find out about security bugs is
we actually pay
people to report security bugs to us and
work with us to improve chrome
so a little over three years ago we
launched the chromium
vulnerability reward program and
the program stipulates that if a
security researcher finds
a bug security bug in chrome and they
report it to us
give us a chance to fix it before before
talking about it
publicly or disclosing to to some third
party
then we will reward them for it when we
launch the program rewards
ranged anywhere from five hundred
dollars to uh elite
which is um uh leet speak for
well common nomenclature for awesomeness
and security
and we quickly uh raised the rewards um
to uh elite and over the past three
years have actually continued to
increase the reward payouts um
just recently this august we're now at
about five thousand dollars to what we
used to pay 500
for and uh
also as the program has has over the
past three years we launched a
complimentary program for
all of google's web properties and
expanded the scope
to not just code that ships in chrome
but any code that or any code or program
that actually could lead to the
exploitation of chrome so we've actually
paid rewards for bugs in adobe flash in
the linux kernel
and i think there was actually even a
windows kernel bug that we paid for
because someone was
able to demonstrate how you could
compromise a chrome user
leveraging one of these other bugs
[Music]
across both programs in the past three
years we've given over two million
dollars
out to researchers um across the the
world
and it's just been a massive success um
from really all aspects it was very
controversial when we launched
originally but as since it's been nice
to see a lot of other vendors
take a similar approach and try to
incentivize and just recognize
security research that that's happening
so
there's a shift in philosophy here um
and really
it's i think we're moving from a state
where software vendors
are embarrassed or trying to hide bugs
and sort of embracing this
there are bugs um tell us about them so
we can fix them
so the vulnerability reward program that
runs
every day all year we've also run a
couple of one-off contests to kind of
spice and spice up the field
where we pay for proof-of-concept
exploits
so these are one-off contests the ones
that google
runs are called podium we've run three
so far
and they typically coincide with a
security conference
and the task is for
a security researcher to demonstrate
that they can get remote code execution
on a machine by just opening up a
webpage in chrome
we've had three contests so far at the
first two podiums
there was a working exploit
there were three working exploits across
three contests and
the payout for these was sixty thousand
dollars for a working exploit
uh pinkie pie is a researcher that
um has has profited um
i think handsomely from from these
contests um
another uh contest that google helps to
sponsor is called pawn to own and this
is actually run independent of google
and it's independent of chrome but in a
similar vein if you can demonstrate a
working exploit on
a computer or whatever the devices are
that are specified at the contest
then you tend to win the device and also
a lot of money and google helps sponsor
these
and then a quick insta instinct um
you know may be why is google paying
people who
are skilled in exploitation and who are
like demonstrating these these working
exploits
and the reality is that i think or you
know at least my opinion is that i think
some of the best
defensive strategies or defensive
engineering comes from a really good
understanding of exploitation
these contests they teach us well they
not only expose
you know real working uh vulnerabilities
that can lead to exploitation they're
proof of concept so
there's nobody that's actually being
impacted by these
they not only teach us about them and um
give us a chance to fix them but they
tend they've they've
been a really good way for us to learn
new techniques
and then um kind of classes of defense
against those
or to find more bugs via those
techniques and also to
understand classes of bugs and build
defenses around those
so you pay for exploits
once we have all those bugs we have to
fix all those bugs
and then something that i think is not
given probably enough
appreciation is actually getting users
updated so it's one thing to fix the bug
it's another thing to actually get
someone patched and one of the
features that chrome shipped with
originally which was actually
controversial
at the time was automatic update
this graph it's not important to focus
on the specifics on either axis but
really to just appreciate the shape of
this it's actually it's an old graph
um because the most recent version of
chrome that it shows is chrome 14 and
and says it's a couple years old but the
idea behind this
is uh every every color represents a
different version of chrome
and what you'll want to notice is how
steep the intersection is
when a new version of chrome is um
launched and sorry the y-axis is actual
um the user base um
that is on that version so you can see
that people are updated
really quickly and nobody likes to you
know restart their software or actually
have to
um you know actively pick click and
update so
automatic update has been um in my
opinion
probably one of the most important
security features that chrome has and
something you know people probably
um take for granted or and and i can
take for granted too
um we've demonstrated
one of the fastest uh bug security bug
report to fix to update um times
in the industry and i have also
demonstrated that we can update users in
less than 24 hours so so for example
i just talked about those podium
contests and
um in both of the first two contests
there was
a working exploit that was demonstrated
to
our security team that was at the
contest and we were able to
send patch users in less than 24 hours
send out
attached users in less than 24 hours
which is probably the thing i'm most
proud of
our response time okay so we update
users
um security bugs fixing updating is
great
at the end of the day security bugs will
exist bugs will exist
it's just an incredibly complex piece of
software that's changing a lot
and it's important to look for bugs and
fix them
and respond immediately but it's equally
important to architect the software
in a way such that the impact of any
single bug
doesn't lead to you know the total
compromise of of the piece of software
and this is really the at the heart of
building in defense in depth which is a
security design principle
to to consider when writing software
one of the ways that we do this is via
sandboxing in chrome
so chrome pioneered the it was the first
browser to have
support for fully isolated file system
sandboxing
for the browser and sandboxing it's a
technique to
break up a program into smaller
isolated pieces that can run that only
run at the highest privileges they
actually need so instead of your whole
having one big piece of software that
runs at the highest privilege it needs
you break up your software and in this
way a bug in any
single piece of of the program
will only the impact will only be as
high as the privilege that that actually
code needs to run out
so chrome has sandboxing at the process
level
we have a small kind of you know
main browser process and then we sandbox
the rendering engine which is
typically very complex and buggy
and thus by sandboxing it we limit the
impact of any bug there so that
your whole system is not compromised and
we also
uh sandbox different plugins
so as i mentioned uh plugins are
really probably just the most vulnerable
part of
modern browsers today given the large
install base
and just history of bad security within
the past six months all of the major
plugins that you probably know
java flash adobe reader have all
been the kind of
way mass malware campaigns have been
marketed there have been
zero days reported in all of these
i could have created a slide with lots
of news briefs but if you search for
them you'll you'll
you'll find it so being able to sandbox
plugins
is also a huge security one for chrome
um
and then there's some other things that
we do to try to
improve plug-in security so i mentioned
that chrome ships with flash natively so
we're able to actually sandbox flash
we also have an integrated pdf reader so
we're able to sandbox that as well too
because we have that inline and chrome
but there's a lot of other plugins that
we can't sandbox because
they're they're outside of the chrome
user base so
we wanted to add some extra defense in
depth for people
um via kind of this threat of plug-in
insecurity
and some of the things we do are we
block plugins that are out of date and
you get a little warning that says hey
you should update your plugin
we'll also by default warn people if a
plugin that
isn't really common and probably not
needed today is actually being
initiated in the browser because it's a
common way that
you would your browser be exploited um
and you just have a lot of customization
for how you want plugins to run in your
browser so you can have all of them
disabled by default
you can whitelist them for for
certain web pages
you can make it so that you have to
actually click to play and all of these
things
are intended to give people the the
power
to control um i guess the
exposure the security exposure that
they're introducing by having plug-ins
okay i'm gonna jump into the next threat
um so we talked about browser
exploitation
uh now i want to talk a little bit about
phishing and and malware
so fishing in malware websites um
the idea here is uh
okay maybe an attacker doesn't need to
have full code execution
and fully compromise the desktop and
doesn't want to spend
all that effort in finding some
vulnerability to exploit
this is what they may go to next um
create a phishing page
to steal private information from a user
or if they have a piece of malware get a
user to
visit the page and either actively or
have it
actively install malware or silently
install
it and usually there's some social
engineering here where someone tells you
it's
you know like a some update
so this is the threat how does chrome
counter threat what is chrome's counter
threat it's something called
safe browsing okay so google down we
we have access to the internet because
we index it and we
serve it back to you um based in search
so since we already have you know this
whole internet editor at our disposal
on top of just looking um for how we
should
best serve this via search queries we
can also decide whether or not we think
a website is trying to cause harm to
users
what safe browsing as a system will do
is
it will open up a web page in a
virtualized environment and monitor what
the web page tries to do in this
environment
if it tries to do something sort of
suspicious
based on a number of different signals
it will mark it as
you know a site a malicious site
and safe browsing is built directly into
chrome so if you try to visit a site
that
we believe to be harmful you're actually
going to get some interstitial
people have maybe seen this uh um
at some point now i'm forgetting the
year it was maybe 2009
we made a little bit of a boo-boo and uh
safe browsing actually blacklisted all
of the internet so any page you visited
uh saw this um
but uh independent of any bugs if you
ever
um have seen an initial industrial place
like this it's because the site that
you're trying to access
we believe to be harmful and there's a
different warning for whether we think
the page is trying to install malware or
whether it's trying to
fish some data from you um but it looks
something like that
and the idea is then that the user
hopefully doesn't click through the
warning but
actually goes goes back or reports you
know
that the warning to the website author
so safe browsing is built directly into
chrome it's also available
as an api and it's built into firefox
and safari too so
across the three browsers um safe
browsing is helping to protect
you know over a billion users which is
um is is quite cool
um and uh as i mentioned it's an api so
uh as a developer i guess here's here's
the one developers
uh factoid you get uh you can use safe
browsing
if you want to you know actually uh
check on any web check websites um that
you maybe would link to
or include in your your application as
to whether or not we think it's
um it's a harmful website or not
safe browsing has also started analyzing
binaries so
we're trying to determine whether we
think a binary
is a virus or piece of malware so if you
download that in chrome
you may get some warning that says this
file appears to be malicious do you
actually
want to download it or discard it
the the thought behind all of this is if
we know something is harmful
we shouldn't even expose we should do
everything in our power to expose people
to not expose people to um you know
malicious content
so sort of this design principle if you
should be safe safe by default
if this is interesting we have started
to publish
a lot more information um on our
transparency report page about safe
browsing data
and you can get you know very specific
data
and graphs about how many malicious
web pages we see in the internet so
whether they're phishing pages or
malware sites
also we show our you know best
instinct as to what percentage of these
sites we believe are actually
attacker websites and which ones are
legitimate sites that have been
compromised by an attacker
so attackers um you know they they know
that legitimate websites already have
um a lot of traffic that are coming to
them so it's easier for them
to compromise some website
serve their malware from that because
there's already user traffic getting
that way
then make their own website and get
people to visit that so you can see from
the graph that a huge percentage of
these bad sites that we're seeing are
actually compromised sites not
bad people creating them and this is a
really
common way that web developers actually
find out about their sites being
compromised
right they start getting complaints from
users that hey we can't access your site
in chrome
and i think the initial instinct um is
we then get a notification like hey
google you're blocking our site
we're not evil and then they actually
you know realize that
oh their website's actually serving um
you know malware and then we try to help
them to to clean up their site
so that's safe browsing as i mentioned
if it's interesting there's a lot more
data and graphs that are published in
addition to like where
in the world we're seeing these sites
and um kind of some
details about trends that you'll see in
the graphs and the specific malware
campaigns that led to them
and the last threat that i'm going to
get into is attacks to
ssl so ssl is
the common and widely adopted protocol
that provides you security and privacy
in your internet communications so
anytime you type https
into a url and visit a website um you
are using ssl protocol to encrypt your
your traffic
um between you and and the service
um this is something you know that's
happening sort of
outside of the browser but it's still a
really uh
you know crucial part to maintaining
internet security so
i want to talk about some of the things
that chrome does to
mitigate common attacks to ssl
uh certainly there could be bugs in the
implementation of it
um but what is the more common um
commonly attacked part of ssl is really
the protocol itself and in particular
the initial key exchange that's that's
used
to set up this encryption so
um if you're accessing your gmail in
your
browser you're going to type https
gmail.com and this will send a request
to gmail and because there's that s
there
gmail knows that you want the student
encrypted and encrypted connection so at
a really high level this is the ssl
protocol handshake and i'm leaving out
some
some details obviously
similar to any similar to most
encryption schemes the first part and
typically the part where there's the
problem is setting up the initial key
that you're going to use to actually
encrypt the traffic
um how this works in ssl is really two
major message exchanges
the first is sort of just a you know
hello from the client
to to the service so from you know in
our case
chrome to gmail and then gmail responds
back
with a hey and also a certificate that
it has been issued to identify itself
but it actually is gmail.com so it's
telling chrome yes you're talking to
you know gmail.com that you want to and
then also
it's public key um chrome
will then or the user via chrome will
then respond
with a client certificate potentially
which is identifying itself
to um the service key information
and then they figure out some crypto
primitives
um and they're good to go from there
where if everything works correctly then
all of your traffic is is encrypted such
that only
you or chrome and gmail can actually
unencrypt it and read it
no matter how many intermediates it
actually goes through
and you know for those of you on wifi
that are accessing your gmail that's
going to be
the router the isp and potentially any
other malicious
um you know third party so that's how it
works
if everything goes well
there have been uh ssl um
is can be vulnerable to men in the
middle attacks um
and the problem here is during key
exchange
um if you know
everything doesn't go exactly right as a
user uh
um and the user doesn't realize that
they're actually
not having an encrypted tunnel to to
gmail but all of this traffic is being
proxied through some third party
there have been there's weaknesses in
potential
problems in a couple of the steps in
this message exchange but
one of the most common ones is kind of
reliance on this
the validity of this certificate and it
really is important
for uh the browser to
trust that the certificate issued is
actually
for the service that you want to access
so um right so
if attacker is a man in the middle then
you may think you're actually
going over a encrypted channel but
you're not
so one of the features that chrome added
in 2011 is something called certificate
pinning
um it's a little bit of a hack and
any time you hard code something it's
it's sort of a hack
chrome comes pre-loaded with the
specific certificates
that it expects to see for google
websites so gmail
and and many other ones too and if
chrome doesn't see those certificates
that are being sent
in a response then it actually won't let
the user visit that page
and additionally it'll actually warn
the chrome security team that like hey
i'm seeing
a certificate that i don't trust that's
being issued for gmail.com something
fishy is going on it looks like
someone's trying to forge certificates
so it's sort of a hack and really if
all that protocol stuff worked well and
certificates were only being issued for
actual um you know service owners of
gmail
this shouldn't be needed but
it's responsible for catching a large
and very significant ssl man in the
middle attack that happened
in august 2011. um i think
the the story here is deserving of its
own 40-minute tech talk
which you know i obviously don't have
but i encourage you to search diginotar
and ssl if you're not familiar
with the specifics of this but the short
version is that
a certificate authority who actually
issues certificates was compromised
attackers were able to issue their own
certificates for
google services and because we have this
certificate pending built into chrome
this was a discrepancy to our white list
of what we'd expect
we got some warnings and then
investigated further and realized that
many users predominantly located in iran
were
vulnerable to man-in-the-middle attacks
so totally not realizing that even
though
it looked like they were accessing gmail
and other services over ssl
there was you know they had no security
or privacy in this connection so
certificate pinning
is cool another feature is
hsts which is the abbreviation for http
strict
transport security so this is
allowing services that really only want
their users to
access them over ssl to actually enforce
this at the browser level
there have been a number of of attacks
and ways to
downgrade users to
accessing a site over http even if it is
offered over https
and this is a way to give services some
power over how
users can access them there's a very
very
so how this works is that you know you
access
a website you access gmail or twitter
or facebook and if you just type in
you know twitter.com your browser is
going to resolve what protocol you want
to access it over
depending on the browser it may default
to http it may default to https
but then the service can actually
respond with this header and say
look browser you should only ever talk
to me over ssl
there's a really small window of
during that first response where
the user may actually access it over
http
um and this is where chrome actually
comes with some
whitelist another hard code a little bit
of a hack but
we white list services any service that
wants to elect into it so that
if you ever access these sites over in
chrome
you'll always access them over ssl
independent of any of these kind of
downgrade attacks that we've seen and
this is not a comprehensive
logo mashup but these are probably some
of the ones people are
maybe most familiar with so
um time wise i'm doing crap
but closing thoughts
so browser security matters i really
believe it should be a factor in the
software you choose
and i'm biased but you know what i would
recommend i think we do some cool things
to combat
current security threats and this was
sort of a probably appropriate
and high level more high level than um
you know what i would have liked to i
think there's a lot of interesting
uh technology and engineering behind
some of these features
uh if you're interested in them
or in any of this we have design docs
and a lot more information available
publicly
otherwise i'm i'm here normally i work
from
our main headquarters in mountain view
california but
i'm happy to chat during the conference
and otherwise
answer emails and thank you very much